Muchos suscriptores nos habéis pedido este vídeo, y la verdad, no me extraña.
La República de China, más conocida como
Taiwán es uno de los países con una situación
desde el punto de vista político y diplomático
más extraña y controvertida de todo el planeta.
Me explico, amigos, en el momento en que publicamos
este vídeo, Taiwán está reconocida formalmente
por tan solo 20 países en todo el mundo…
y, ojo, algunos de ellos tan peculiares como
El Vaticano, Tuvalu o Suazilandia.
(Por cierto, los países más importantes
que siguen reconociendo a Taiwán están en
Latinoamérica. Son El Salvador, Nicaragua,
Guatemala, Honduras, Paraguay y la República
Dominicana).
Pero, la verdad, amigos, veremos por cuánto
tiempo lo siguen haciendo…. Luego entenderéis
por qué digo esto.
(El caso, es que, a pesar de todo, Taiwan,
ha conseguido meterse en el club de los países
más ricos y más libres de todo el mundo,
cuenta con un poderoso ejército de más de
300.000 hombres muy bien equipado y es una
de las puntas de lanza de Estados Unidos en
el sudeste asiático).
Pero ¿Qué es lo está ocurriendo en Taiwán?
¿Qué podemos esperar de este pequeño país?
Estas son algunas de las preguntas que vamos
a contestar en este vídeo, pero antes echemos
la mirada atrás y veamos donde empezó todo.
LA GRAN SEPARACIÓN CHINA
La peculiar situación que hoy vive Taiwán
tiene su origen en la gran guerra civil china
que tuvo lugar entre 1927 y 1949.
(Esta guerra enfrentó a las fuerzas conservadoras
del Partido Nacionalista Chino, liderado por
Chiang Kai-shek, con las fuerzas del Partido
Comunista Chino liderado por Mao Tse-Tung)
Pues bien, el día 10 de diciembre de 1949,
cayó Chengdu, la última gran ciudad china
en manos de los nacionalistas.
La guerra había terminado y los comunistas
se habían llevado el gato al agua.
Poco antes de caer Chengdu, un avión que
transportaba al líder nacionalista, Chiang
Kai-shek, partió rumbo a Taiwan, la última
provincia bajo su control.
(Junto a él se refugiaron en Taiwán dos
millones de personas y los restos que quedaban
del ejército nacionalista. De esta forma,
Taipei, la ciudad más grande de la isla pasó
a convertirse en la capital de la República
de China).
Desde entonces, aunque Mao trató de apoderarse
de la isla en alguna que otra ocasión, Taiwán
recibió el apoyo decidido de Estados Unidos,
que siguió reconociendo al gobierno de Taipéi
como el gobierno legítimo de China hasta
nada menos que 1979.
(Como curiosidad cabe decir que la fuerza
aérea de Taiwán fue la única del mundo,
junto a la de Estados Unidos, que operó de
manera asidua los célebres aviones espía
U-2. Su misión era vigilar a la China de
Mao. La mismísima CIA dirigía los operativos).
Sin embargo, en esos años Estados Unidos
estaba tratando de ganarse el favor de Pekin
para hacer una especie de operación pinza
contra la Unión Soviética,
como por cierto ya nos contó Alberto aquí, en VisualPolitik.
Pues bien, en 1979, el por aquel entonces
Presidente de Estados Unidos, Jimmy Carter
decidió establecer relaciones diplomáticas
con Pekín y eso supuso dejar de reconocer
como homólogo al gobierno de la República
de China, esto es, al gobierno de Taipéi.
Veréis, Taiwán nunca declaró su independencia,
durante años el gobierno de Taipéi siguió
considerándose como el gobierno legítimo
de toda China.
Y claro, diplomáticamente un país solo puede
tener un gobierno reconocido.
(Así es como surgió la política de una
sola china que hoy es seguida por Washington
y por la mayoría de países del mundo. Un
giro, que, por cierto, le supuso a Taiwan
perder su puesto en la ONU y prácticamente
todos los organismos internacionales).
Eso sí, Estados Unidos siguió comprometido
con la seguridad de la isla, y también en
1979 el congreso estadounidense aprobó el
Acta de Relaciones con Taiwán,
un documento que se reserva la opción de
velar por la seguridad y defensa de la isla,
algo que EEUU ha hecho, desde entonces.
Pero como os decía al comenzar el vídeo,
nada de esto ha conseguido evitar que Taiwan
protagonice una de las más grandes historias
de éxito económico y social.
EL GRAN RUGIDO DEL TIGRE
En los años 50, Taiwán era un lugar muy
pobre, con una economía muy rudimentaria,
donde casi todo lo que vendían al mundo eran productos agrícolas como azúcar y arroz
Pero claro, esto no era suficiente, la isla
necesitaba recursos para garantizar su supervivencia.
(En ese momento el gobierno pensó que tenía
que lograr que los empresarios de la isla
pudieran vender productos industriales por
todo el mundo. Y qué mejor manera de lograrlo
que abrirse al mundo y favorecer el ahorro.
Sí, ahorro, para poder invertir primero hay
que conseguir los recursos que hacen falta.)
Dicho y hecho, el gobierno de la isla pronto
comenzó a eliminar prácticamente todas las
restricciones a la importación,
de esa manera sus empresarios podían hacerse
de forma muy competitiva con todos los productos
que necesitaban para poner en marcha sus negocios
y cadenas de producción.
Es algo similar a lo que hizo, Singapur.
(Por otro lado, la cultura del ahorro y la
seguridad jurídica hicieron que el país
tuviese una capacidad de inversión enorme.
Pronto las empresas comenzaron a crecer como
setas y a exportar todo tipo de productos
al resto del mundo).
En 1980 los productos industriales suponían
ya el 90% de las exportaciones del país y
crecían de media ¡un 30% cada año!
Taiwan vendía de todo al mundo: juguetes,
radios, bicicletas, calcetines… de todo.
Y claro, en esa situación, como os podéis
imaginar la renta per cápita de los taiwaneses
no paraba de crecer. En apenas 30 años se
multiplicó por 5.
Había nacido, amigos, un nuevo tigre asiático.
(Aunque no todo el camino ha sido tan de color
de rosas. Taiwán no se convirtió en una
democracia hasta prácticamente los años
90. Eso sí, una vez alcanzada la libertad los
taiwaneses se han abrazó a ella).
Hoy Taiwán es la undécima economía más
libre de todo el mundo y la tercera de Asia,
tan solo por detrás de Hong Kong y Singapur;
es un país rico, con un nivel de vida bastante
alto y está en el club de los países con
más libertades civiles.
De hecho, amigos, Taiwán está a punto de
hacer historia:
(“Taiwán será el primer país asiático
en legalizar el matrimonio homosexual”.)
Cómo veis la comparación con la China continental
no aguanta comparación alguna.
En términos per cápita, los taiwaneses son
hoy tres veces más ricos que los chinos y
mucho, muchísimo más libres.
Pero, vale... a pesar de ello, también hay
algunas nubes en su horizonte.
NUBES EN LOS CIELOS DE TAIWAN
La verdad es que los últimos años el país
está sufriendo algún que otro problema.
De hecho, en 2015 el país padeció una pequeña
recesión y desde entonces el crecimiento
económico de la isla se ha enfriado mucho.
Llegados a este punto hay una pregunta clara
sobre la mesa ¿Qué diantres está pasando?
Pues son varios los ingredientes de esta amarga
receta que está enturbiando el presente de
la isla y que también amenaza su futuro.
Atentos.
(La competencia de China y de nuevos mercados
emergentes, como Indonesia o Vietnam; la fuga
de talento; el envejecimiento poblacional;
o, por ejemplo, un sistema de pensiones prácticamente
quebrado son algunos de los factores que han
provocado que los salarios lleven años prácticamente
congelados y que el crecimiento económico
sea muy bajo).
Precisamente el sistema de pensiones es, con
diferencia, uno de los más grandes quebraderos
de cabeza del gobierno de la isla.
Mirad, durante años las pensiones de los
trabajadores públicos fueron infladas por
motivos políticos, es decir para ganar votos
y esto,a migos… sale caro, muy caro.
Las pensiones públicas fueron tan infladas
que hoy han puesto en jaque a todo el sistema
(El salario promedio mensual de un trabajador
en Taiwan es de 1.300 dólares americanos.
Por su parte la pensión de un maestro jubilado
asciende de media a 2.234 dólares americanos,
un 75% más).
Lo sabéis, las malas políticas salen carísimas.
Pero... continuemos con la receta.
Al siguiente ingrediente lo podemos denominar
como el problema del 40-40.
(Fijaos, la economía taiwanesa es muy dependiente
de la industria electrónica y del comercio
con China. Los productos electrónicos suponen
el 40% de todas las exportaciones y por su
parte China es el destino para el 40% de las
exportaciones taiwanesas).
Y puede que te preguntes ¿qué tiene esto
de malo? Pues que cuando la industria electrónica
o China no van bien pues el país lo nota.
Y eso es, precisamente lo que ha ocurrido
por ejemplo con la desaceleración china en
los últimos años.
(“Cuando la China continental estornuda,
Taiwán está hospitalizada en la unidad de
cuidados intensivos”.)
Y luego, tal vez por encima de todos los demás,
hay un problema político que afecta mucho
al país y que por ejemplo ha provocado que
la Inversión Extranjera en Taiwán sea bastante
menor que la de los países vecinos: el temor
a China.
LA AMENAZA CHINA
Este es con diferencia el principal problema
al que se enfrenta Taiwán.
El gobierno de Pekín está empeñado en recuperar
la soberanía sobre la isla y en sus declaraciones
públicas afirma dos cosas:
primero, que esto ocurrirá antes de 2049,
el año del 100 aniversario de la República
Popular China
y segundo que está dispuesto a utilizar la
fuerza si Taiwán intenta declararse independiente.
(Taiwán es de facto un país independiente.
La isla tiene su propio presidente, elegido
por cierto democráticamente, sus propias
leyes y sus propias fuerzas armadas. Sin embargo,
Pekín no está dispuesto a aceptar esta posibilidad;
lo más que está dispuesta es a concederle
a Taiwán de forma temporal un status similar
al de Hong Kong).
Y esto, ojo, es un problema grave, entre otras
cosas porque la mayoría de los taiwaneses
ya no sienten ningún lazo de identidad con
China.
Sienten que son, sencillamente, ciudadanos
de un país libre que lleva siendo independiente
casi 70 años.
De hecho, cuando en 2014 el anterior gobierno
de Taiwán quiso acercarse demasiado a Pekín
y, como decirlo... transigir con alguna de
sus tesis, se produjo la llamada revolución
de los girasoles y cientos de jóvenes se
apostaron en el Parlamento al grito de ¡Taiwán
no se vende!.
(Precisamente, bajo este clima de frustración
económica y política, en enero de 2016,
el Partido Demócrata Progresista, un partido
cuyas bases son mayoritariamente independentistas,
ganó las elecciones legislativas y también
las presidenciales. Tsai Ing-Wen, poco cercana
a Pekín, se convirtió así en la primera
presidenta de Taiwán).
Aunque probablemente la economía fue el factor
decisivo, esta elección a Pekín le ha
sentado fatal. Tanto que ha reanudado la política
de acoso y derribo contra Taiwán.
(En lo que llevamos de 2017 el turismo chino
a Taiwán se ha reducido un 40%, Pekín ha
conseguido que dos países, Panamá y Santo
Tomé y Príncipe dejen de reconocer a Taiwán,
y está impidiendo la presencia de la isla
en muchos foros internacionales).
De momento, no han tomado represalias económicas,
pero en la Isla saben que esto podría suponer
un duro golpe para Taiwán.
Por eso entre las prioridades del nuevo gobierno
está enfocarse, urgentemente, a nuevos mercados.
Pero, puede que os estéis preguntando ¿Y
EEUU? ¿Donde está EEUU? ¿Qué dice de todo
esto?
Pues de momento parece que su apoyo a Taiwán
se mantiene intacto.
De hecho, recientemente el gobierno de Trump
ha aprobado una nueva venta de armas a Taiwán
por valor de casi 1.500 millones de dólares.
(“EEUU enfada a China con la venta de armas
a Taiwán por $1,420 millones".)
Y, además, recientemente, el poderoso Comité
sobre Servicios Armados del Senado de Estados
Unidos,
aprobó con el voto mayoritario de sus miembros,
tanto del Partido Republicano como del Partido
Demócrata que los buques de la marina puedan
utilizar de forma operativa los puertos taiwaneses.
Si las cámaras aprueban finalmente esta propuesta
el cabreo de Pekín va a ser de aúpa.
Pero ¿Cuál es el objetivo de Washington?
Pues sobre todo intentar que a Pekín no se
le pase por la cabeza siquiera una invasión
militar.
En fin, así están las cosas. Desde VisualPolitik
estaremos muy atentos a todo lo que ocurra
en esta pequeña isla.
Pero ahora es tu turno ¿Cuál crees que debe
ser el futuro de Taiwán? Puedes dejarnos
tu opinión en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Como siempre si el vídeo te ha resultado
interesante, dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.